مشاهدينا ازمه كبيره تتمثل بانتاج الاسلحه
بعد ان احرقت الحرب في اوكرانيا العتاده
الغربي بمعدلات لم يتصورها الغرب وفق صحيه
صحيفه دور ستريت جورنال التي اعتبرت ان
الدول الغربيه تاخرت كثيرا باعاده بناء
صناعتها الدفاعيه وحرب اوكرانيا شكلت صدمه
وجلس انذار للقاده الاوروبيين واستصاعد
خطر نشوب صراع مع الصين ايضا
لاعاده تحريك سوق تصنيع الاسلحه لمسانده
اوكرانيا لكن هذا الامر يتطلب سنوات من
العمل وميزانيه كبيره لتلبيه الحاجه على
الارض هذا الامر اكده امين عام حلف الناتو
معتبرا ان تصنيع الاسلحه يحتاج الى عقود
من العمل ويجب بذل المزيد من الجهد في هذا
الاطار وقبل ذلك كشف استوتنبرغ اتفاقا على
ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الناتو على
المدى البعيد
اتفق اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي على ان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في تحالفنا ولكن في
نفس الوقت هذا يعد منظورا طويل المدى
الموضوع الان هو ضمان ان تعود اوكرانيا
دوله مستقله وذات سياده وبالتالي نحن
بحاجه لدعم اوكرانيا